[Música]
[Aplausos]
se hizo saber a todas las muchachas
casaderas del reino que se celebraba un
gran baile en el palacio real el motivo
encontrarle una esposa al príncipe y
convertirla en princesa y así fue se
celebró la gran fiesta el príncipe
estuvo toda la noche bailando con una
bella y misteriosa joven que tuvo que
recogerse tempranito y a las doce
justamente abandonó abruptamente el
baile dejando atrás un precioso zapato
de cristal de swarovski comodísimo
el pobre príncipe ha llorado yo creo que
esta palabra no se usa nunca aturdido e
instantáneamente enamorado se percató de
que no tenía el móvil de la chica y el
correo electrónico ni el lista gran nada
tan solo tenía en su poder un zapato de
cristal con dos tiritas pegadas la parte
del talón
el pobre príncipe estuvo vagando por
toda la comarca con el zapato colocado
en un cojín citó de terciopelo monísimo
probándose lo a todas las muchachas pero
es mal que las potenciales princesas no
tienen hongo ni le huelen los pies
pero finalmente finalmente como estaba
profundamente enamorado aunque nos había
quedado con la cara de la chica porque
tenía que andar probando zapatos vale
como estaba profundamente enamorado
encontró a su media naranja porque nadie
nadie en todo el reino excepto ella
cansado 37
encontrar encontrar a la media naranja
de dónde viene esto plato en su obra al
banquete nos muestra las enseñanzas de
aristófanes que para explicarnos cómo
cómo era la humanidad al principio de
los tiempos nos decía que la raza humana
tenía cuatro brazos cuatro piernas una
forma redondeada y una cabeza redonda
con dos rostros opuestos entre sí había
de tres clases una clase compuesta de
hombre hombre otra clase compuesta de
mujer mujer y una tercera clase
andrógina compuesta de mujer hombre
estos seres estaban desafiando
constantemente a los dioses porque eran
fuertes potentes y muy soberbios júpiter
encontró la fórmula de reducir sus
fuerzas sin tener que aniquila a toda la
humanidad
la solución cortarlo con la mitad de
esta manera destinarían muchas de sus
fuerzas en encontrarse y así fue tanta
energía destinaban en encontrar a su
otra mitad que muchas veces morían de
hambre de seis de frío porque se sentían
en definitiva lo que viene a decirnos
que solo existe una persona perfecta
para cada uno y cada una de nosotras
porque si partícula naranja por la mitad
cada una de las partes sólo encaja con
la otra evidentemente nuestro actual
modelo de amor romántico se basa en este
antiquísimo modelo que ya nos contaba
aristófanes se basa en la familia
tradicional en la monogamia en las
relaciones estables y en el matrimonio
es por esta manera de entenderlo que la
soledad suele percibirse por el entorno
como algo que debe ser pasajero ya que
el supuesto estado natural de las
personas es estar en pareja y si el
supuesto estado de las personas están en
parejas en pareja y la monogamia
obviamente la ruptura y los divorcios
pues se perciben como un fracaso con
toda la connotación peyorativa de la que
hemos dotado al fracaso pero pensado una
cosa
cuando le damos a una persona la
responsabilidad de que complete nuestra
vida como si fueran un tetris
no solo nos cuesta mucho más despedirnos
de una manera sana sino que es mucho más
fácil caer en la dependencia en el
control en los celos y nuestras propias
carencias
creemos que queremos que nos las
complete otra persona y cuando eso no es
así vienen las peleas los repros y los
yo te dije tú me prometiste pero claro
es verdad que todas las personas no
somos igual de permeables a los mensajes
potentes que nos transmiten sobre el
amor pero si hacemos memoria todos y
todas en alguna ocasión hemos caído en
esta manera de actuar bueno y si a esta
manera de amar esta manera de entender
el amor no funciona porque no la ha
cambiado pues no la cambiamos
básicamente por varias cosas en primer
lugar nos aferramos a creencias
consolidadas socialmente porque nos dan
seguridad y ese es el cambio de creencia
da miedo lo desconocido es raro que
ambién de algo que no sabemos cómo va a
ser puede incluso tener un reproche por
nuestro entorno es como decirle a
alguien del madrid que sea del barcelona
o al revés
prácticamente imposible verdad en
segundo lugar no cambiamos esta idea del
amor romántico porque atacamos a la
genética comportamiento que realmente
son culturales y en base a eso decimos
la típica frase yo es que soy como soy
decimos eso y eliminamos toda
responsabilidad de cambio pero qué bueno
es cuestionarse qué bueno es plantearse
lo todo cuestionarte tu manera de ser tu
manera de estar en el mundo tu manera de
entender el amor tu manera de entender
la política la religión todo debería ser
revisable porque en definitiva a eso eso
es lo que nos hace evolucionar lo que
nos hace llevar al crecimiento personal
y en tercer lugar no cambiamos esta idea
del amor romántico porque a veces no
somos ni conscientes de que tenemos
comportamientos tóxicos en nuestra
relación
y no somos conscientes porque estamos
rodeados de relaciones tóxicas por todas
partes las encontramos por ejemplo en
los cuentos que dice cuento dice
leyendas fábulas mitología e incluso las
religiones
las religiones que a través de historias
nos cuentan cómo debe ser la moral a
seguir cómo son los orígenes de el
universo e incluso nos explican cómo
debemos formar una familia tradicional
con su paloma y todo
pues los cuentos crearon tradición los
cuentos son una de las formas más
antiguas de literatura popular la
mayoría de los cuentos clásicos
provienen del folclore medieval nos
explicaban la moral a seguir eran
cuentos adoctrinadores se dirigían tanto
a la infancia como a personas adultas
estos cuentos eran más crueles que
empezar a una dieta un viernes
es más en el cuento original de la
cenicienta una de las hermanastras se
llega a cortar los dedos de un pie para
poder encajar el zapato
y es que verdaderamente hacemos
barbaridades por encajar con la media
naranja
el príncipe que era un avispado de la
vida
se da cuenta de que no es su amada por
la sangre del zapato
nos había quedado con su cara en verdad
a mediados del siglo 19 las versiones de
los cuentos empezaron a suavizarse
quedando aptas para educar os acordáis
de la sirenita
sí verdad las sirenas aparecen en la
odisea de homero
homero ya sabes quiénes no y odiseo
ulises en latín ulises es el héroe por
antonomasia el superman al que todos los
chavales querían imitar bueno por ulises
después de la guerra de troya tarda 20
años en llegar a su casa que se debió de
parar todos los bares gabias
bueno pues ulises para demostrar que es
el héroe pues tiene que sortear
numerosos obstáculos para salvar a su
tripulación y uno de esos obstáculos que
se encuentran son las sirenas las
sirenas que son una criatura mágico
acuática mitológica mitad mujer mitad
pescadilla
que con su embaucador canto llevan a los
a los navegantes a una horrible muerte
en alta mar
hans christian andersen rescata a esta
figura y hace un cuento y la versión más
reconocible por todos y todas es la
versión de la sirenita de walt disney
pictures en 1989 o acordáis ariel
ariel
ariel es una chica pizpireta y cantarina
que está harta de vivir en el pueblo
bueno en el mar ariel ve de lejos un
humano instantáneamente se enamora de él
aunque no sabe ni siquiera si le huele
el sobaco
y recurra a las malas artes de la bruja
úrsula para que le dé una pierna sin
pelo
también
pero por supuesto no vaya a ser que le
deje de querer cuando le salgan los
[ __ ]
a cambio la bruja le pide su maravillosa
voz su voz
la muchacha no tiene mucho que decir o
no lo considera importante porque por
ese amor verdadero de ese que te surge
con alguien que conoces de vista es
capaz de ceder su mayor talento cambiar
drásticamente su cuerpo y abandonar a su
familia
finalmente la cosa acaba en moda como la
mayoría de los cuentos los doce casas
casualmente el es un príncipe rico y
apuesto
ella pasa de acuáticas hortera terrestre
consorte
[Aplausos]
y mientras los cangrejos muertos a los
palillos y las gafas a las palmas
precioso verdad
los cuentos influyen mucho más de lo que
pensamos de nuestra infancia es la
manera que tenemos de entender el mundo
con sus arquetipos con sus ideales y se
influyen tanto en nuestra infancia
irremediablemente influye en nuestra
edad adulta un ejemplo de cómo influye
en la edad adulta de todos los cuentos
es el cine la mayoría de las películas
de corte romántica comercial o de drama
tiene el mismo patrón que los cuentos
por imitación porque por costumbre o
porque es más reconocible en nuestro
imaginario voy a poner un clásico de los
90 por poner un ejemplo pretty woman
podría por un clásico de los 50 una
película de este año pero este aseguró
que él ha visto un target más amplio
además está catalogada como una de las
películas más exitosas en la historia
del cine en venta y en publicidad pretty
woman empieza así
se ven imágenes de los bulevares de
hollywood precioso y una voz en off
bienvenidos a hollywood todo el mundo
tiene un sueño cuál es el suyo cuando
era pequeña soñaba que era prisionera en
la torre de un castillo y llegaba un
príncipe en un caballo blanco a galope y
me rescataba
al final de la película de pretty woman
llega el businessman
montado en su limusina blanca con su
ramo de flores y las rescata de ella de
su ático de pobretona
y que si tiene que una repetición
clásica del patrón de la cenicienta pero
que se olvidan detallitos de está
cositas como que aunque richard que nos
lo presenten como un galán guapo y con
dinero en verdad era un [ __ ]
x
también se le olvidó otro detallito que
la mayoría de las mujeres que se dedican
a la prostitución tienen una vida que
poco tiene que ver con la comedia
en definitiva porque cuando están pretty
woman que la hayamos visto 40 veces lo
ponemos otra vez
porque nos emocionamos cuando se muere
leonardo dicaprio en titanic
cierto el spoiler vale
pero que sepáis que el titanic se hunde
bueno y cuando en gosh nos ponemos un
poquito tono cuando están los dos con el
barro aunque estén haciendo una [ __ ]
del cenicero que estamos nos ponemos un
poquito tono pues nos sentimos así por
culpa de las neuronas espejo las
neuronas espejo son unas células del
cerebro que funcionan de la siguiente
manera hace que nos sintamos igual
cuando estamos viendo una acción que
cuando la estamos realizando son las
responsables de la empatía y del
aprendizaje por imitación es decir si a
la empatía que sentimos ante
determinados personajes
le sumamos que estos personajes nos
codifican como como debe ser el amor el
aprendizaje por imitación está más que
asegurado
películas cuentos leyendas canciones
pasodoble de carnaval telenovela todo
descansa sobre una manera de entender el
amor
son factores de socialización muy
potentes que no que conforman nuestro
imaginario y qué hacemos qué hacemos
ante esto
nos cargamos los clásicos del cine de la
literatura la esa es la opción unimos
fórmulas alternativas cuentos
alternativos películas que potencian el
pensamiento divergente que haga que
nuestras neuronas espejo se entrenen de
otra manera puede ser pero realmente hay
hay cuentos alternativos y películas
alternativas pero no funcionan o no son
suficientes o no son muy potentes porque
la idea del amor ahora hemos cambiado
qué hacen necesitamos una construcción
nueva
o cambiar la que hay pero cómo cambiar
de equipo es algo prácticamente
imposible
podemos darle un giro cómico a la
construcción que ya existe es decir
dotarla de sentido del humor
el sentido del humor es un sentido más
común que el propio sentido común y poco
habitual con lo que contradictoriamente
no es muy común pero con el sentido
común podemos relajarnos relajamos esos
roles esos aprendizajes dejamos de
ponernos a la defensiva ante el miedo
que nos provoca el cambio y con el
sentido del humor podemos ser capaces de
vislumbrar en un momento de crisis un
momento que puede ser de cambio de
transformación
y como aplicamos el humor en este
proceso mediante la creatividad muchas
veces pensamos que la creatividad es una
habilidad innata y no es así
la creatividad es una habilidad que se
entrena que se crea fuerza de repetición
de ensayo mediante la creatividad
podemos cambiar una creencia en una
parodia de ella misma para que para
rebajar tensión emocional voy a poner un
ejemplo
tienes que encontrar a tu media naranja
yo soy una naranja completa que puede
estar sola en el frutero que le pueden
gustar los kiwi
por los pelitos
es más bueno también es decir que a la
piel de naranja le cogió cariño
fuera quien bien te quiere te hará
llorar
quien bien me quiere me hará tener un
montón de orgasmos
más orgasmos de lo que tengo de manera
autónoma
sin ti no soy nada sin ti no me
desintegró como una magdalena angoli
bonan un café
lo pasaremos algún tiempo pero lo
superaré créeme
el amor requiere entrega y sacrificio el
amor no es riesgo de cada un piso
está la cosa ahora con la cláusula como
para añadirle cláusula al amor fuera he
tenido varios fracasos sentimentales he
tenido tanta experiencia que cada vez
apuntó mejor
tenemos que subir fotos a las redes para
demostrar nuestro amor mira la gente le
da igual que tú cuelgue una foto con tu
surry en una puesta de sol o en la playa
con dos unicornio
y dos delfines saltando le da igual tu
relación no es un anuncio de colonias
cuando tienes que demostrar tanto hacia
afuera que algo hacia adentro no
funciona heteronormatividad esto no se
dice es más bien algo implícito la
mayoría de los modelos que nos proponen
y de los arquetipos que vemos son
heterosexuales y si integramos la
diversidad de manera natural nuestro
cerebro se expande sin límite y eso es
maravilloso
si dicen no es si no es no
mariposas en el estómago hambre
se te va a pasar el arroz si se me pasa
el arroz leyó fideo ya está
en definitiva la risa provoca placer en
nuestros cerebros la elección la tenemos
en nuestra mano donde nos situamos en el
humor o en el drama el concepto de amor
es mutable y moldeable hasta las
creencias más consolidadas se pueden
desmontar con humor si le dotará mos al
concepto del amor de más humor y de
menos drama no solo sufriríamos menos
sino que seríamos capaces de establecer
relaciones mucho más saludables
en definitiva el humor reblandece
creencias muchas gracias
ah
[Música]